hey guys it's Anne welcome to the
channel if you're new here and you are
looking for a very active worm Community
that's always willing to answer your
questions then you are in the right
place today we're looking at my red
wigglers in the DIY three stack system
and one of the things I want to talk
about today is should you go to the
trouble of making your own DIY system or
should you just spend the money and get
a professional setup
so as I'm going to go through and
evaluate what the bin needs today I'm
just going to talk about my journey and
the fifth year of having my DIY system
that I made myself
so last time we did a really big Harvest
to get some castings and so we also fed
them some decent amount of food so let's
see what they've got left and see what
they need for today so looking at the
top layer here this is where I returned
the worms to the system you can see they
made some nice castings right there
and kind of just gonna go through here
and fluff everything up and see what
we've got
I'm seeing quite a bit of bedding here
but I'm not seeing anything in the way
of food on this layer
so in the nice warm weather you can
expect for your worms to
do really well
I mean not really hot I mean I think if
you have the worms outside and it's 100
degrees Fahrenheit the worms will
probably go dormant
but in a basement that is you know 80
degrees Fahrenheit then the worms just
keep plugging along and continue to do a
really good job
so you can see the moisture is a little
bit low in here
but I tend to run my bins a little drier
just so that I have an easier time
harvesting
because the last time if you watched the
last video I did a light Harvest and
that is a lot of work and it really kind
of annoys the worms so I do try to avoid
doing that and I try and at least get
one layer to be kind of dryish so I can
sift
so there's really nothing to see here on
this layer it looks like there's some
old corn cobs here a little bit of
um
avocado shell but other than that
there's no food on this layer just looks
like casting's embedding
let's look at the next layer down
okay so this layer down here has a lot
more moisture and that is always the
case with this bin
so the top layer stays dry because I
don't put a lid on it
I find that the worms actually crawl
more if you put a lid on because that
keeps the sides of the bin wet and then
they just want to go exploring and see
what's going on
if you keep the top of the bin a little
bit dry then they are less nosy and they
tend to stay inside of their
um
inside the bedding and inside the bin I
did have a question about that and
another thing that worms tend to crawl
is if you have a very new bin and let's
just call new bin younger than six
months old
um under six months old the environment
of the bin is just not established and
so it might not be as comfortable and
home like
for the worms and they might still want
to go seek other places but once you get
your bin to a nice equilibrium where the
microbes and the moisture and everything
in here
feels good to them they don't really
tend to crawl too much
now that's red wigglers I'm talking
about in particular
other worms have different personalities
or traits like African night crawlers it
doesn't seem to matter what you do in my
area they crawl
but not seeing anything in this and it's
been about three and a half four weeks
since we looked in on this bin before
so all of these castings are you know
still doing good that mango last time
wasn't wanting to open and it's still
not wanting to open yet but this is
probably a really happy moisture for
them you can make kind of a ball but it
falls apart very easily
if you're into wanting to grow your herd
of worms herd is that the right word I
don't know if you want to grill more
worms then actually more wet than this
is the preferred you know moisture you
want like 80 percent moisture if you
want to encourage them to breed
I don't need more worms so this is just
fine for me it's not unhealthy it's just
not uh perfect breeding moisture
let's look at the next layer down
so this layer and these are risers this
just keeps everything from getting
compacted
um
that was a suggestion by one of the
viewers to uh keep this part from
becoming completely compacted
and make it better for the worms so I
started doing that and it absolutely has
worked
now this bottom layer here is very very
wet
this is probably an ideal breeding
condition for the worms
probably about 80 percent moisture in
here you could make mud balls with this
the springtails are a springing in here
they definitely like this moisture level
as well
and although they're annoying to me they
are a part of the worm bin community and
they do help break down things that are
too hard for the worms to eat
by themselves
so one of the things I wanted to talk
about as far as the the DIY bin
is that I made it five years ago and the
plastic is starting to give way I'll put
an inside a picture there
any place where I've drilled a
significant hole in it like the sides or
the the bottom
I am finding that that particular
plastic is failing and uh this
particular bottom layer does not have
any holes on it at all no holes in the
bottom no holes in the side This was
meant to be a sump where all the liquid
would drain
um
but if you watch the
the playlist of this you'll discover
that at some point I decided that since
so many worms were coming down there and
drowning I might as well just put
bedding down there for them to live if
they were going to do that
so this bottom part rarely gets anything
other than refresh of bedding time over
time it the worms I don't know the hole
that goes down into this layer is a
sixteenth of an inch which is only a
couple of millimeters and so most of
these worms probably came down here when
they were much smaller and they're
probably just stuck down here now
because
they probably can't get back up through
you know a two or three millimeter hole
at you know adult size
so I'm going to leave these guys here
and we'll put the second layer
on so looking at this second layer here
I'll show you what I'm talking about
foreign
and sure enough just as I said I don't
think adult worms can make it through
that three millimeter hole
there's a reasonably adult-sized worm
going through the two millimeter hole
well
I guess like I always say worms do what
they want
so this layer down here is
in a good condition
but we're going to give them some food
the side of this bin is broken and kind
of jagged so it seems like if you do a
DIY system
depending on the quality of the plastic
and these were you know name brand
Rubbermaid
containers so in theory I would have
thought the plastic would have been high
enough quality to withstand being a worm
bin for many many years but I think five
years might be the limit on these guys
cost me about thirty dollars for the
three bins and then when we take a
closer look at the top I also drilled
some large holes and then put screen on
there
that's not even necessary but that's
what I thought I needed to do in the
beginning
so
um but I'm starting to see where any
place that there was good sized holes
I'm seeing that the plastic is starting
to break
and I do have to wonder after looking
online at the different plastic
stackable systems they're warrantying
the plastic for 20 years so I'm starting
to think it's not the same kind of
plastic from a Rubbermaid tote to a
professional stacked worm system
so let me get them some food
let's see so they're going to get a
tomato and some zucchini
another tomato
and an avocado peel so onions tomatoes
so they've got their own guacamole
makings if that's what they want to do
and I'm just going to cover that back up
with the the regular castings here
and let me put the top on and I'll show
you what I mean about the larger holes
and things are starting to break
so I have the half inch holes that I
um hot glued screens on to to keep
larger Critters out
most of them have fallen off and the
ones that are still there just the
slightest little bump and they come off
I found out later these are really not
necessary I mean it was it was a nice
DIY project but
um you know now what I know about worms
is that
a worm would have gone through that if
they needed to if they wanted to escape
they could have gone through regular
window screen which is all that is
and looking at the bottom of the bin
here
looking at the larger holes
these are starting to break out a little
bit in a few places and although you
know it still works the bin is starting
to deteriorate so even though I spent
thirty dollars on this bin it seems that
maybe five years is as far as the
quality of plastic is going to let me go
so put in the comments below you know if
you have a DIY system that's stacked
like this how long did yours last and
was it worth it I started looking into
professional stacked systems and they're
running about a hundred dollars ninety
to a hundred dollars U.S
for a five stack system I think you can
get three stack systems for about eighty
dollars but they're also warrantying the
plastic for 20 years so I am really
starting to Second get guess myself was
this good for a starter until you can
save up money or you know would you do
this again if you already had
the hundred dollars let's just make it a
flat one hundred dollars
if you could afford to spend that you
know should I have done that to begin
with okay let's get these guys some food
up here now all the frozen food will
thaw out and the drippings will go to
the lower level
and for any tomato lovers out there yes
having this large tomato rot on me get
bought Blossom and draw it when the uh
the floods started coming that really
does hurt for me to feed it to the worms
although I know that they will make good
use of it and help my plants later it is
very painful to throw away that large of
a tomato
okay so we're gonna cover that up and
straighten these guys out
so just reflecting on the last five
years of this DIY bin
so after five years the plastic is
coming apart in any of the hot glue
stuff is is falling off
when these trays are completely full
each one of these trays weighs about 25
pounds maybe even 30 pounds with wet
castings and depending upon your level
of activity that might be okay but I'm
getting to the point where I can't pick
this whole thing up if it is close to
being finished because it weighs you
know 50 or 60 pounds depending and
um that's just a backache looking to
happen so I'm not
I try not to fill it all the way up
anymore because it gets so heavy that
you know it hurts my back
not to mention that the quality of the
plastic it is starting to bow in the
middle
I did start putting those risers in
there which I forgot in case anybody
notices if I didn't notice I I did just
now notice the pile of risers that I'm
going to have to disassemble and put
them back in
but yeah so
it bows in the middle
and it's starting to break down and it
is super heavy so I am starting to you
know seriously consider swapping these
worms out and putting them into a
professional stacked system
uh just basically for ease of use of me
because each one of those anybody who's
got a stacked professional system
um please chime in and let me know how
each one of those how much each one of
those waves when it's full
and that kind of might make me make my
decision because if each one of those is
only 10 pounds then that's not going to
be a problem so that is where I'm going
right now is yes it's cheaper yes it
saves space going vertical
um you know which does make more
castings which is why instead of using
just bus trays I used this
uh in the beginning but now I'm just
seeing that this plastic is breaking
down so what do you guys think should I
get a professional system when this this
thing is slowly dying on me or should I
go and get another DIY system
all right guys well if you like this
series I have an entire playlist that I
will link right over there and if you've
already seen that YouTube thinks you're
going to like that video over there okay
guys thanks for hanging out with me and
my worms and everybody have a good day